do you know if the clothes you're
wearing were made by forced labor
do you know if your laptop was made with
conflict minerals
do you know if the chocolate you eat is
made by child labor
or if your smartphone was made by
someone paid fair wage
we want businesses to check what impact
they have on the environment
on labor standards and on human rights
and if they find problems in their value
chains
such as pollution or dangerous working
conditions they need to do their bit to
solve them
at the moment there are not many
companies that do this
yes there are some international rules
but they are voluntary and they haven't
led to the change we need
the aim of this legislation is that harm
like child labour bribery or
deforestation will be avoided
but if not companies will need to
compensate victims for the harm done
to target marxism
[Music]
no more hiding from our responsibilities
to the people and to the planet no more
breaching human rights for profits
no more victims paying the price for
profits